a man police described as the stepfather
of a missing four year old Texas girl
will appear in court this morning in
connection with her disappearance Darian
Vince is accused of tampering with human
remains even though no body has been
found
Malia Davis was last seen more than a
week ago Matea via al is in Houston with
the latest details of this investigation
but a a good morning we know good
morning the assistant district attorney
here in Harris County says there is a
substantial likelihood the darién vents
will face additional charges possibly
including murder but so far
investigators have not publicly said if
they believe vents killed Malia this
morning investigators will once again
scour areas of Houston for Malia Davis
Tim Miller is helping lead the search
for the missing four-year-old I would
like to hold on to that hope she's alive
out there somewhere Darrien vents
reported Malia missing more than a week
ago the 26 year old was arrested on
Saturday after investigators found new
clues inside the South West Houston
apartment where he lived with Malia and
her mother drops of blood linked to
Malia and evidence someone tried to
clean it up a Houston TV station says
these surveillance photos show vents
entering the apartment on April 30th
with Malia just steps behind him but she
was never seen coming out more photos
reportedly show vents leaving the
apartment three days later while
carrying what prosecutors described as a
blue laundry basket with a garbage bag
and bottles of bleach prosecutors say
investigators found a blue laundry
basket and a gas can inside the car
vents claims was stolen from him by
three men with Malia inside prosecutors
also say cadaver dogs detected the scent
of human remains inside the car
civil rights activist Quan LX represents
Malia's mother Brittany poets he
describes events as Bowens ex-fiance and
says Rowan's recently called off the
engagement when that happened I believe
that he psychologically snapped already
on top of being abusive to Malia he did
is to hurt the mother in the way that
she would never recover
Vence is in jail on a 1 million dollar
bond has a court-appointed attorney
court documents obtained by our CBS
partners KHOU report that Malia was
removed from the home last year after
Child Protective Services actually
thought there may have been abuse inside
that home by the parents now police tell
us that vents multiple times has changed
his story about her disappearance Thank
You Maria the story makes me so sad and
so angry - yes you know we thought at
the beginning there was something fishy
when he told the story about his little
boy was found and the little girl was
missing when you see the pictures of her
going in after him and company and
appearing to come out what looks like a
laundry there are security cameras
everywhere very very upsetting story